rester anonyme parce que le dossier est
encore en cours andréanne bissonnette
est une de ces femmes qui se disent
abandonnés par le système judiciaire
elle a appris il ya quelques mois
qu'aucune accusation ne sera déposée
pour le viol qu'elle affirme avoir subie
quand elle avait 18 ans ça va vraiment
être un processus difficile de prendre
la décision d'aller porter déposer ma
plainte parce que je croyais pas
vraiment au système c'est comme si on
faisait en fait tu avais raison d'un
doute et puis ça fonctionnerait pas le
premier ministre françois legault s'est
dit ouvert à l'idée d'un tribunal
spécial sur les agressions sexuelles
comme le préconise la députée péquiste
véronique hivon
radio canada a appris que la rencontre
organisée par la ministre de la justice
sonia lebel avec des députés des partis
d'opposition pour amorcer une réflexion
sur l'accompagnement des victimes aura
lieu lundi après tout le courage qui a
été démontré par les par les victimes
d'agressions sexuelles
tout le courage qu'ils étaient
démontrées dans la foulée du mouvement
mais aussi je pense que c'est la moindre
des choses que comme élu on se creuse
les méninges
on se met à l'ouvragé pour trouver des
solutions pour rebâtir la confiance
moi je vais beaucoup beaucoup plaidé en
faveur de tout ce qui est le travail en
amont du tribunal c'est à dire que les
femmes en grande majorité où les
victimes il ya des hommes aussi ne
seront pas jusqu'au tribunal donc qui
est un grand travail d'accompagnement on
veut s'assurer que les plans qui sont
pas retenus
il ya un processus de révision
systématique selon statistique canada
entre 2009 et 2014
un cas d'agression sexuelle sur cinq s'y
retrouver devant les tribunaux et un sur
dix s'est soldé par un verdict de
culpabilité
on sait que les agressions sexuelles
sont les crimes au canada les moins
rapportés et pour lesquels il ya le
moins de condamnation les faits art
on ne peut donc pas dire que le système
de justice fonctionne un tournant
spécialisé apporterez une meilleure
expertise mais je pense qu'on pourrait
plus rapidement maîtres sont en branle
si des gens ont travaillé sur cette
expertise là par une formation juste
d'avoir un système qui est particulier
aux agressions sexuelles permettrait
d'avoir un accompagnement qui est réel
et qui à toutes les étapes du processus
il allait de l'avant le québec sera la
première province au canada est un des
seuls endroits au monde à se doter de
tribunal spécialisé sur les agressions
sexuelles
la nouvelle-zélande a lancé un projet
pilote sur la question l'afrique du sud
quant à elle est un des seuls pays en
avoir un le taux de condamnation des
crimes sexuels a d'ailleurs augmenté
depuis sa mise en place et si marie
laurence de l'année radio canada
montréal